GREG GUTFELD.
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY, AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE." WE BEGIN
WITH A MAJOR DIPLOMATIC
BREAKTHROUGH WITH NORTH KOREA.
A SECRET MEETING JUST REVEALED
CIA DIRECTOR MIKE POMPEO MET
WITH KIM JONG UN OVER EASTER
WEEKEND, PAVING THE WAY FOR A
POTENTIAL SUMMIT BETWEEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THE
DICTATOR.
THE PRESIDENT SPOKE ABOUT THE
TRIP AND HIS SECRETARY OF STATE
NOMINEE AT MAR-A-LAGO.
>> I THINK MIKE POMPEO IS
EXTRAORDINARY.
NUMBER ONE AT WEST POINT, TOP AT
HARVARD.
HE'S A GREAT GENTLEMAN.
I THINK HE WILL GO DOWN AS TRULY
A GREAT SECRETARY OF STATE.
HE JUST LEFT NORTH KOREA, HEDDA
GREAT MEETING WITH KIM JONG UN,
AND GOD ALONG WITH HIM REALLY
WELL, REALLY GREAT.
HE HAS THAT KIND OF A GUY.
HE'S REALLY SMART BUT HE GETS
ALONG WITH PEOPLE.
SO I THINK MIKE WILL BE IN GOOD
SHAPE.
WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE PREDICTING
OTHER THINGS.
BUT I HAVE A FEELING IT'S GOING
TO WORK OUT VERY WELL, AND I
THINK OUR COUNTRY REALLY NEEDS
HIM.
HE'S GOING TO BE A GREAT LEADER.
>> Jesse: THIS IS PRETTY HIGH
LEVEL, KIMBERLY.
JAMES CLAPPER, PRESIDENT OBAMA'S
TOP INTEL CHIEF, WENT OVER
THERE.
MADELINE ALBRIGHT WENT OVER
MIKE POMPEO GOES OVER THERE ON A
SECRET MISSION, PRETTY BIG.
HOW DOES THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION NOT GET SUCKERED
INTO A DEAL LIKE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATIONS, THE BUSH AND
ADMINISTRATIONS, AND MAKE THAT
SAME MISTAKE.
>> Kimberly: MIKE POMPEO
SOMEBODY HAS, I AM NOT GOING TO
SPEAK TO THE NATURE AND
QUALITIES OF PAST
ADMINISTRATIONS BUT AS IT
RELATES TO POMPEO, THE
RELATIONSHIP HE HAS WITH THE
CIA, THE POSITION IS IN.
IT'S A WISE CHOICE AND IT SHOWS
THE UNITED STATES IS WILLING TO
ENGAGE IN DIPLOMATIC LIVES OF
DISCOURSE TO BE ABLE TO SOLVE
COMPLEX GEO PARTICLE PROBLEMS.
IT'S A POSITIVE FOR EVERYBODY.
TAKING IT SERIOUSLY, PUTTING
FOCUS AND ATTENTION ON THE,
BEING OPEN-MINDED.
WE WANT TO TALK TO THEM AND WORK
OUT SOMETHING IN A GOOD WAY
THAT'S GOING TO BE BENEFICIAL,
NOT JUST TO THE UNITED STATES
AND NORTH KOREA, SOUTH KOREA,
CHINA, BUT GLOBALLY, THE WORLD
AT LARGE.
PUT SOME POSITIVITY INTO IT.
HOPEFULLY HE'S GOING TO BE ABLE
TO MAKE SOME INROADS.
YOU CAN'T DO ANYTHING UNLESS YOU
TRY.
>> Jesse: HE IS TRYING.
HARD, AND HE'S NEGOTIATING FOR
VISION OF STRENGTH, UNLIKE
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATIONS.
A DAY NOW, SOME OF THE OTHER
DEMOCRATS ON THE SENATE INTEL
COMMITTEE ARE NOT SO HAPPY WITH
MIKE POMPEO.
THEY MAY VOTE AGAINST HIM FOR
THE WHITE HOUSE IS SAYING PLEASE
DON'T UNDERCUT HIM DURING THIS
OVERTURE LIKE THIS.
WE HAVE SOME SOUND OF SOME
DEMOCRATS EXPLAIN THEIR
POSITION.
LET'S LISTEN.
>> DIRECTOR POMPEO HAS SHOWN
DISDAIN FOR DIPLOMACY, PUTTING
MILITARY ACTION AT A HIGHER
PRIORITY.
I THINK HE SETS A POOR EXAMPLE
IN TERMS OF AMERICAN VALUES.
SO I WILL STRONGLY OPPOSE HIS
NOMINATION.
>> I DO EXPECT FOR SOMEONE WHO
IS THE NOMINEE TO BE THE
SECRETARY OF STATE, WHEN HE
SPEAKS WITH THE COMMITTEE
LEADERSHIP, AND WHEN HE WAS
ASKED SPECIFIC QUESTIONS ABOUT
NORTH KOREA, TO SHARE SOME
INSIGHTS ABOUT SUCH A VISIT TO.
>> I THINK THE DIPLOMAT THAT
REPRESENTS THIS COUNTRY AS
SECRETARY OF STATE, ESPECIALLY
UNDER THIS PRESIDENT, HAS TO BE
SOMEBODY WHO REALLY HAS A STRONG
ORIENTATION TOWARD DIPLOMACY AND
NOT SOMEBODY WAS GOING TO
EXACERBATE THE PRESIDENT'S WORST
TENDENCIES.
>> Dana: IT TAKES A LOT TO GET
ME WORKED UP, BUT I WORKED UP
ABOUT THIS.
HOW IS IT THAT BLUMENTHAL,
SENATOR FROM NEW JERSEY, CAN
SAY, OR CONNECTICUT, CAN SAY
POMPEO HAS A DISDAIN FOR
DIPLOMACY?
HE SPENT HIS EASTER WEEKEND
FLYING TO NORTH KOREA TO SIT
DOWN AND ACTUALLY TALK TO
KIM JONG UN WHICH I BELIEVE IS
DIPLOMACY.
THE PRESIDENT ALSO BENEFITS FROM
THIS BEING THE BEGINNING OF HIS
ADMINISTRATION WHEN THIS IS
HAPPENING.
FOR EXAMPLE, MADELEINE ALBRIGHT,
WHEN SHE WENT, THEY ONLY HAD TWO
MONTHS LEFT.
PRESIDENT CLINTON HAD A CHOICE.
HE COULD WORK ON MIDDLE EAST
PEACE OR NORTH KOREA.
HE CHOSE TO MIDDLE EAST PEACE.
THAT DEAL FELL APART.
LATER TELLS MADELEINE ALBRIGHT,
I WISH I WOULD HAVE DONE THE
NORTH KOREA DEAL.
THINGS HAPPEN.
PRESIDENT OF PRESIDENT.
I FEEL LIKE THE DEMOCRATS ARE
PICKING A FIGHT THAT THEY DO NOT
WANT TO HAVE.
I DON'T THINK THEY WILL WIN IT.
IT'S NOT SUSTAINABLE TO HAVE
THIS ARGUMENT.
THE OTHER THING ABOUT
SENATOR MENENDEZ BEING
FRUSTRATED THAT POMPEO DIDN'T
TELL THEM.
HE IS SAYING HE WASN'T
FORTHCOMING IN HIS TESTIMONY.
WELL, YEAH, BECAUSE HE HAD A
SECRET MEETING TO GO TO
NORTH KOREA, AND HE IS THE CIA
DIRECTOR.
THEY CONFIRMED HIM A YEAR AGO.
TO ASSUME THAT HE CAN'T BE CIA
DIRECTOR, HE CAN'T BE STATE
APARTMENT HAD BUT CAN RUN THE
CIA IN NINE MONTHS IS
PREPOSTEROUS TO ME.
I THINK THIS IS A REALLY BAD
EXAMPLE FOR THE UNITED STATES TO
SET FOR THE WORLD.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO LIKE MOM     -
YOU DON'T HAVE TO LIKE MOM
YOU DON'T HAVE TO LIKE MOM     O
YOU DON'T HAVE TO LIKE MOM     '
YOU DON'T HAVE TO LIKE MOM     T
HAVE TO LIKE MIKE POMPEO BUT LET
HIM DO HIS JOB.
>> Greg: HOW CAN THEY HANDLE
THIS KIND OF ACHIEVEMENT FROM
SOMEBODY THEY DESPISE?
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO TRUCK IN
THOUSANDS OF THERAPY LLAMAS FROM
PERU TO DEAL WITH THE MENTAL
BREAKDOWN THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
WITH ALL OF THE HATERS WHO WANT
SO BADLY FOR TRUMP TO FAIL, EVEN
IF A SUCCESS COULD MEAN AN
INCREDIBLE TRANSFORMATION IN
WORLD SAFETY.
I MEAN, IF YOU DENUCLEARIZE
NORTH KOREA UP, IF THIS HAPPENS,
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO MAKE
ROOM ON MOUNT RUSHMORE.
>> Jesse: JUAN, GET THE CHISEL
OUT.
>> Greg: MUST BE HARD FOR CNN
AND MSNBC BECAUSE THEY ARE TOO
BUSY COVERING A --
IMAGINE IF CNN WERE AROUND WHEN
THE BERLIN WALL FELL.
THEY WERE      WOULD BE COVERING
THEY WERE      WOULD BE COVERINA
THEY WERE      WOULD BE COVERINL
THEY WERE      WOULD BE COVERINV
THEY WERE      WOULD BE COVERINE
BOAT REUNION.
THAT'S HOW STUPID THIS IS.
I THINK IT WAS A WEEK AGO OR SO,
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT HOW COMEY
SAID HE COMPARED TRUMP TO A
MAFIA BOSS.
I THINK WE REALIZED A MAFIA BOSS
BEATS A MASSAGE THERAPIST.
IT'S NOT A BAD THING TO HAVE
SOMEONE WHO TALKS TOUGH WHO
RESET THE TABLE AND IT COMES
DOWN TO A SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE
NOTICED.
TRUMP ENTERS, HE THROWS THE
TABLE OVER AND SAYS EVERYTHING
HAS CHANGED NOW.
HE TAKES THE HARDEST POSITION,
AND YOU HAVE TO WALK TOWARDS
HIM.
THEY UNDERSTAND THAT LINKAGE.
YOU CANNOT UNDERSTAND AMBIGUOUS
INTELLECTUAL PARALYSIS OF
ANALYSIS LINKAGE.
BUT YOU CAN UNDERSTAND THAT.
I THINK THAT'S WHY THIS IS
WORKING.
>> Jesse: GREG IS SAYING HE
CAME IN AND HE PULLS OUT OF TPP,
PUTS THE SECURITY DEAL ON THE
TABLE WITH THE SOUTH KOREANS,
SLAPPED SANCTIONS ON THE
CHINESE, WAR GAMES WITH OUR
ALLIES LIKE JAPAN AND
SOUTH KOREA.
IT LOOKS LIKE THINGS ARE MOVING
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
DO YOU GIVE THE PRESIDENT ANY
CREDIT FOR ANY ACTION HE HAS
TAKEN?
>> Juan: I WAS WAITING FOR YOU
TO TELL ME WHAT MOVED IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION.
>> Jesse: THIS IS A HISTORIC
SUMMIT.
>> Juan: POTENTIALLY.
>> Jesse: 60 OR 70 YEARS ON
THE EVE OF A HISTORIC SUMMIT
BETWEEN THE NORTH AND SOUTH.
>> Juan: IT'S NOT LIKE THE
FIRST TIME PEOPLE HAVE GONE OVER